I'm literally recording this because I
needed to remind myself that I think I'd
tweeted at somebody that I said that I
might voice something in this game and I
forgot about it and this is me saying
that I'm gonna remember to do that now
uh new goat new goat just dropped go to
sucker to love sucker oh man Sucker For
Love day to die for this is the demo
this is not the actual game so my
reminder still stands there still is
time for me to do what I whatever it is
I said I was gonna do unless I didn't
say that and this is really embarrassing
anyway welcome back to soccer for love
if you remember the first one it's a
dating game
but if you don't go check it out it's
fun Cosmic Horrors
things beyond our understanding they are
sequestered to the Stars appearing only
through challenging failure-prone
rituals and an utterable incantations
they're Twisted fanatical followers
require no such invitation to commit
Horrors beyond belief in their stead it
is then when the boogeyman lurking In
the Shadows isn't an obscure
imperceptible shade but a tangible
madman me vague prognostications of the
stars become empty threats before the
undeniably material me I'm undeniably
material in their hands oh oh did
something scary happen hmm
huh huh in the book you're reading did
something scary happen you hear his pale
as a sheet
oh no no I must have nodded off and had
a bad dream
nah I know this is a super weird
question but can you tell me where I am
you're in my bookstore in Sacramento are
you lost
Sacramento
oh no I think I know where I am now
thanks I'm beginning strange dreams
lately I can't make sense of what
they've been about when I wake up my
heart is pounding out of my chest and
I'm not where I fell asleep these dreams
started happening the same time that
people began Vanishing for my hometown
Sacramento
even though it's a fairly remote town
with a small population there's been
dozens of disappearances in the last
year alone so many that the trains don't
stop at the station anymore
why would they stop doing that concerned
locals claim to have spotted angry
Woodland Spirits at the edge of the
woods animals with too many features
feet watching them and Outsiders can't
shake the feeling that they're always
being watched by the unblinking purple
eyes of the Town folk the Sacramento
stairs what they call it on the news
they're saying that the stairs how they
can tell if you're an outsider at a
glance if you don't have it I know
you're not one of them oddly enough I
don't have the Sacramento stare despite
being born here and even now after
returning home I have still been spared
from it besides some light-headedness
and a dull warm fuzzies feeling I don't
feel any different the girl that runs
this odd bookstore also hasn't been
cursed it seems have you made a
selection
did you find a book to your liking oh
yes
oh yes I did oh I'm sorry no I didn't I
didn't mean to loiter to be honest I
don't have any money with me but I'll
come back first thing tomorrow and buy
something no it's fine I'm glad that you
enjoyed reading my books but it's
starting to get dark outside with all
the disappearances lately you better
hurry home why do you look familiar
home even though my family fled town
when the disappearances began I'm
returning to our ancestral home of
Sacramento all because of a note that I
found in my apartment this morning
your mother is a little shook up from
everything that happened and so I'm
taking care of her at Graham Grammy
conde's place
if you came to visit who would cheer up
and help a recovery we'd miss you so so
much Stardust
I don't think that's what that says but
the strange thing is my parents were two
of the first people to go missing they
were declared dead since they've been
missing more than a year admits the
disappearances this is their handwriting
and my parents are the only ones that
call me Stardust this is them beyond a
shadow of a doubt whatever is going on
here I can't turn my back
I need to see them again speaking of
I better get going thanks for letting me
doze off I promise I'll come back real
soon real soon why do you look familiar
thank you for stopping in take care I
saw when I was the high mellow
right time to hurry back
I push my way through the door leaving
the Warm Glow of the bookstore behind as
the sun sets Sacramento overgrown Now by
oppressive canopies of foliage from the
smell of animal musk and swampy Fields
you'd think this was a barn not a city
street
every surface here is plastered with
posters many litter the ground and every
single one of them is someone that was
never found that's why they call it
missing person lame now it's we're
desperate Out of Towners looking for
their loved ones leave posters before
going missing themselves it's the only
navigable footpath left and the most
direct route to my house
I can't tell if it's the Darkness
playing tricks on me what I'm losing my
way down streets that I should know
forwards and back wasn't I supposed to
make a turn while ago I can't make heads
or tails of the houses and landmarks as
I used as a kid to get around
it's like my whole home town was
replaced by an unfamiliar yet exact
replica
okay calm down if I check the note my
parents wrote and compare the address to
the nearest house I should be able to at
least figure out if I'm walking the
right way
oh a blank grocery store receipt when
did I put this in my pocket where's my
parents letter
I dig through my pockets in a panic
there's no way I dropped it in the
bookstore so where could it
this receipt it has the same fold lines
and dimensions as the handwritten Note I
I could I have
no there's no way I could have misread a
shopping list as an entire letter from
my parents right I thought more around
with a note checking the back and
flipping and turning it in a hopeless
attempt to see the message again but the
receipt stays a receipt
something's very wrong
oh are you like blind or something watch
where you're going clots of Rama okay
that's a little rude you wanna you want
a little punch of the face was that what
you want I slam right into somebody come
the other way
oh I'm sorry are you all right I should
have been more careful
whoa she's really pretty but what on
Earth is this girl doing wandering
around Sacramento at night
okay
sorry I didn't mean to smack into you
like that I know it's not an excuse but
I was just in a rush oh yeah
yeah really cool save your breath I
already know how this goes
what
your boyfriend
you heard me my boyfriend Buck is mine
what who the heck is Buck where all
these accusations coming from I I don't
own a new book really
don't know who Buck is no you're not
like
from out of town are you
the stair it's real I turn my head down
in briskly walk past her she starts
walking alongside me look at me
I don't know if I want to I can't let
her see my eyes no matter what she'll
notice I don't have the Sacramento stare
you can tell me
from here or what I mean technically
yeah I live here yeah look at me really
quick
it's bad even if I make it home she'll
know where I live what do I do
I freeze before I know it I'm already
staring straight at her
okay I break into a Mad Dash running my
hardest everything is a blur my heart
pounding in my ears can't dull out the
sounds of the whistles shouts an
unidentical commotion coming from sides
panting and dizzy I feel my body slowing
down but the image of my face on the
next missing person's poster kicked my
legs into action once more but no matter
how far I run buildings refuse to change
the streets refuse to turn and the
sounds of the Awakening Woods refuse to
Abate the Surplus is wide open clearing
in the trees about one block ahead if I
can break line aside from my unseen
pursuers I have a chance of finding some
place to hide has any other turn off my
exhaustion makes itself known if this is
a dead end or if it's too dark to find
my way I won't have the energy to turn
around and start running again around
the corner it's my grandma's house
sitting alone in the middle of a
clearing in the woods I thought the
weight of my house involved multiple
turns ways back but I don't have time to
question things as I'm already halfway
up the makeshift turn path
so when do I get to smooching anybody
smoochable in here that's a lot of shoes
I skulk up the open lawn in my
grandparents old house burst through the
door and hold the door shut for what
feels like forever no one's banging at
the door for the moment I'm not being
chased hey what's
I may just be standing at the entrance
but I can already tell something feels
off about my home like the warm familiar
place I grew up in is long gone I can't
put my finger on it but this dread why
do I feel like I need to sneak around my
own home is someone here
my parents hey butterfly
hello I'm home no response
hello
a butterfly a butterfly stuck in a web
where's the spider
this is very different from what I
thought it was going to be but I'm okay
whoa
smooching
all right okay all right okay how do I
oh
[Laughter]
that's cool
oh that
oh that's cool
oh
it's like a full-on old school
exploration horror game
oh God I hate that
no wait hold on
oh this is fascinating our family photos
only none of these photos have been in
it and the faces of my siblings look
unfamiliar what's with those strange
symbols
what's with a bucket of blood I would
like to know what the bucket of blood is
about I feel like the bucket of blood
okay it's a lot of Hearts everywhere
that means it's prime time for smooching
hey yep
yep
okay good good good
oh
like I know that this all dealt with
Cosmic Horrors and Eldritch uh demented
beings the bird cage where my grand
Graham kept her finches it's been
distorted from the inside
oh that's worse
oh horrific
anyway I'm hungry
oh all right
fresh dripping meat I should avoid
counting the number of legs
[Music]
but but uh
I mean I guess it's fine if I have
nothing to say about it hello
well this is Grand I unusually pungent
spices pepper nutmeg ginger and cinnamon
do we name a couple I see there is
almost suffocatingly thick with their
scent
okay well that's Grand this is a lovely
house
truly lovely what's that terrible smell
coming from that fridge I can't bear to
open it of course you can't looks like
cooking oil except it's in a gallon
container and it smells like burnt hair
and sulfur the colors black as said too
other than that just like cooking oil
just like Graham Graham used to make
anyway oh peekaboo
that's probably this way
shoot
well
nothing concerning here
this is such a good premise for a horror
game which now this has become
I'm just gonna say that straight up it's
pretty horrific at the moment
just very very horrific oh oh hello oh
where am I
I don't think I should be anywhere kind
of outside
I feel like being outside is probably a
bad idea
very bad
hold on I wasn't quite done in here
hello okay
okay
yep
oh
man how many people
no stop
I thought that beanbag had somebody in
it looks like the triplets toys have
been mostly untouched ever since we left
in a hurry
with the triplets toy what triplets what
triplets are you talking about what a
mess the cloth has been ransacked but no
valuables have been taken also lots and
lots of beds why so many beds
yeah that's the entrance
when do I get to smooching
listen I got this game for the smooching
of it I'm not seeing enough smooching
that looks haunted
oh
okay
um before I do that I'm gonna go this
way and into here
concerning ship hello
[Music]
kind of empty in these family homes oh
cool perfect
well that's comforting and familiar
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
nothing to see here perfectly fine
there's one room I didn't see here
I'm probably fine
okie dokie I've seen all I need to see
you
yup that's concerning
yep
ladder room
blue ladder ladder
why the ladder room I'm definitely not
going down there unless I have to I have
to
I have to this smooching you don't
understand
it's smooching time we really aren't
emphasizing smooching nearly as much as
you should how if that is your real name
well you get to the point of the matter
which is just the smooch
that's what I know and that's what I
learned it doesn't matter if you get
your face melted off your balls blasted
off your legs turned inside out you live
for the smooch you die for the smooch
and we're boy howdy do I plan to
bathroom hello
I've seen better days
toilet
Turtle it
tree
[Music]
let all right well that's not weird
oh
that's lovely
[Music]
oh
is that my bedroom
it is my better but before I do that
I don't know why but I want to explore
everything it's blocked from the other
side I can't see clearly Through the
Keyhole either
huh am I gonna be living with Eldritch
gods
wait a minute
wait a minute somebody has plastered my
kids sibling study room with dirty
posters I'm gonna beat whoever did this
senseless senseless
hmm interesting
all right the plot thickens
see what the hell is going
well
what the heck happened in my room
it's called stuff sitting around has
someone been living here while I was
away
those candles are lit whoever did this
was here recently but who why
maybe there's some kind of clue in this
book there's no title or author or
anything and it smells like overripe
fruit and formaldehyde in other words it
reeks of death my hands feel pruning a
nice cold touching the cover like it's
drinking the life from my fingertips
like the very material of this item it's
thirsty
seeding black woods instructions on how
to corrupt the soil of a forest by using
awful of a goat in the Beating Heart of
a human the beating what I read and
re-read the passage but it's plain as
black and white the Beating Heart of a
human I reread again and again my
disbelief washing away more and more
each time this isn't a joke first the
stare that only the locals have then The
Disappearance is then the supernaturally
overgrown woods and now this book
describing sacrificial rituals the truth
Dawns on me Sacramento has been overrun
by cultists people haven't been Spirited
Away by Angry four Spirits they've been
inducted and up next I can't stop
trembling should I hide is there even
anywhere to hide I certainly can't run
these cultists could be anywhere I
hastily flip through the book maybe
there's something anything that I can
use to escape amidst hundreds of pages
and indecipherable runes and obscene
rituals one catches my attention
manifest the all mother according to
this the our mother is supposed to be a
benign Eldritch entity with profane
powers of Life preservation nothing else
in this book looked even remotely benign
If This Book Is For Real then this all
mother is my best shot at getting out of
here live summoning a space demon is
probably a bad idea but my odds haven't
couldn't have and couldn't get in any
worse than they have already they
haven't found a single person that went
missing besides there's still a chance
that this book is fake right but there's
an explanation for all the weirdness
happening in Sacramento I better hurry
and do the ritual and find out looks
like I already have everything I need to
try
uh
you're right I definitely do uh
ah I found the plan misser at certain
times in conversation this icon will
appear and you can spray the speaker
with water by right clicking the
this feature was primarily included in
consideration players who dislike being
hit on by older women Eldritch
Abominations but it does other uses too
and who would that be
two
[Music]
looks like the idol of a goat only it
has too many legs too many eyes weighs a
ton too have this get up the stairs
a big hole
most of life's mysteries are solved by
noticing the big hole okay
now we are back into the game this
entity is a benign preserver of life and
cannot harm you I'll have no contact
with Elders Gods is completely safe
swallowing does any lit candles okay
snuff
easy in sure there is an idol of the
black goat present summer in the room
Roger that Idol of goat
have a plan Mister with you while facing
a tree of the black woods chant her name
that looks like a tree of the black
woods I don't see any other trees of the
black woods all right
Roxanne
you dare
yep it worked this book is for Real how
do they get their hands on something
like this
form of the black goat of the woods of
sails my senses the birthplace of life
and birthplace of love and final resting
place of death the maker and unmaker in
all her undulating auror of vile sailing
whose seeps from the pores of my
clenched fists as I'm overcome by
another worldly nausea beyond my
Reckoning
extensive on my soil long enough today
is the end of empty threats
okay Roxanne
come near fertilizer for my black woods
blood trapped within my distended veins
quickens surging agitatedly beneath the
Flesh of my cheeks
nurturing forth from the wicked soil to
feed upon your ever suffering remains
for all of time at my hands you will die
again and again
again
okay why are you blushing
oh well
you didn't need to call me
girl pretty oh my God
[Music]
[Laughter]
I thought I was driving you insane oh
that's sweating and hyperventilating it
looked like you were gonna throw up
uh no
oh that just happens when I talk to
girls
I'm usually not into goats actually I'm
never into goats but um I'll make an
exception foolish mortal your impudence
has made me very
oh forget it what is it this time
torture again
no I'm not no no no where did you catch
your cold mate with someone else and now
you want me to pretend to be your mommy
to comfort you that would be horrible I
would really not appreciate that at all
told me torture I think I've been
confused for someone else
probably only have a few more moments
but
breaks your will so make it quick I
don't think that usually happens to me
in my past experiences with Eldritch
Gods my will was broken long before my
lust got there so I feel fine
I mean she's dropped at gorgeous and I
feel like my heart is beating out of my
chest but I don't feel like my will is
breaking or anything
I am a goddess of first
fruits and you are standing two feet
away from me at the very epicenter of my
carnal influence
and you're telling me you don't feel a
thing
okay I know we both know what your
carnal influence and where its epicenter
is um but can you just let's just can
you just say it out loud just for
everyone else who's around all the
cultists hidden in the walls what is
your carnal influence
I don't read a lot of books lesser
Warhammer I mean I think you're really
beautiful that's all you think I'm just
beautiful
sure I'm closer and take it hey
back away
point
goddess of lust getting rejected by her
own cultists in her own dream
huh
uh I don't know if this makes it worse
or not but I'm actually not anybody's
cultist
makana just said it I thought that was a
bag under your eye I didn't know that
was another eye that's
I can Overlook it I wasn't looking at
your eyes anyway I mean sorry I've
summoned you because my life is in
danger and I thought maybe you'd be able
to help me somehow
so unless you lift my chin and pulls my
face close to her
[Music]
you're not under my influence nah you're
not one of them yeah how did you get
this book I was on the ground what do
you mean I just found it on the floor
grave grave danger the Thousand doesn't
know you're here yet but they will be
coming for you you've got nowhere to run
coming we'll be able to escape
now while I'm still rooted here any road
you walk will lead straight back here
well that's where I wanted to go anyway
you need to do the rituals in that book
in Order ending with a spell that will
uproot me from this location once I've
been uploaded you'll be able to run for
it and hope for the best okay don't let
anything happen to the book if you lose
it before I'm uprooted
way out okay
a chill is running on my spine run for
it no way out grave danger carnal
influence just what have I gotten myself
into scaring you
you have no choice if we're ever going
to
ashes was like that scared me a little
bit wait a minute did I just hear
something right hold on it sounds like
you're trying to escape too
messy with my cultists I see it in a bad
way I mean
my followers have turned against me and
are abusing me and my Woods's power to
kill Outsiders indiscriminately okay
is a nightmare that I'd just like to end
but neither of us can leave without the
uprooting ritual being performed okay
but I should warn you
these incantations and rituals can be
terrifying for a non-cultist to perform
you can successfully completing them can
have grave consequences no I know all
about grave Colonel consequences these
rituals will test your medal in ways
that
I'll do it really
you're just okay with what I'm saying
yeah
if there's a way out just tell me how
I'll do it
so many people have gone missing I'm not
letting the same thing happen to me
or you let's not waste any time start
with the spawn partner ritual first
you'll need it spawn spawn
how spawnable we how spawnable we
talking here yeah whoa why can't I go
home
where have I gone that's cool
that's pretty neat pretty nifty that's
fun
the woods fatten themselves on us the
dead feed the woods the living feed the
woods whose blood is the tree bleeding
this is uncomfortable
no
no oh that's lovely this one's nice
all right okay what was I doing
oh those seeking to destroy the
blackwoods instead become compelled to
worship at the roots of the Blackwood
spread to the mind
all right light the ritual candles the
color of the flame does not matter so
please choose the color you find
comforting have your choice of the
narrow manic herb on your person pick a
scent you find Pleasant imagine your
ideal partner if it exists it will
appear before you if it does not exist
it will be created do not imagine
something you can't put back chant
all right uh so I know where to get some
aromatic spices are you in here
oh
why so sad what are you so sad
so these followers are kind of like
jealous ex-boyfriends then you want
nothing to do with them but the only way
you leave yes
be right you're like my exes and using
the same metaphor if you try to date me
then my exes will hack you to death with
farm tools that is an app metaphor that
last part wasn't a metaphor okay
maybe I should get back to the rituals
then probably a good idea yeah I got
many good ideas you gonna find out about
how many good ideas I have
like
eating
toast in the morning
after we
hang out that's a good idea
all right
whatever that is in this room of course
it is I was going to the kitchen what am
I an idiots for hey remember that great
idea I had have another one
ah
don't
drink too much water
more less than two hours before the bed
you're gonna have to piss all over
yourself
um
I have ah this thing's uh I got
all right
pick a scent you find Pleasant oh okay
what do we got lavender that's pretty
good mint rosemary is good on food but
lavender I would I would take lavender
over mint I think okie dokie then and
that
[Music]
I know this says black not really black
candles green no
is that blue it looks green
oh change it to I see okay light it red
change to Black
nah again that's really not that I gotta
go with pink
pink not bad
all right let's do this I'm imagining
something
tall I'm imagining the thing that Matt
pack could never imagine for me which is
the not the perfect poke that's not what
I'm talking about something else really
tall uh here we go
oh oh
my
I I can explain
I'm gonna explain well if you remember
all my good ideas well you've
[Music]
you're pinkish you got
pink someone
and your hair is
[Music]
I've got nothing
there's no need to be bashful especially
after all that time you spent playing
koi
in the view of the circumstances
perhaps I will allow you to be my
partner
really and that's okay with you even
though we just met well it's subtle and
it'll be a long long time before I could
ever trust a human again
but I'm not exactly the god of taking
things slow
[Music]
I already have a thousand children
there's no harm in a thousand and one
well that's a little presumptuous in
either way I could understand that
that's a little
all right what are we talking about
taking me as your partner
huh
I thought you were talking about just
being my girlfriend
definitions of Partners
goddess was referring to the platonic
meaning
yes
there's three meaning of Partners
cowboy
joking around while standing so close to
me you should be melting with desire uh
being anywhere within a mile of me
should amplify your lost a thousand fold
oh that's an easy one a thousand times
zero zero
I don't know what I just said
um
you you aren't with child now not that I
know of you're going to die here and
there's nothing I can do to help okay
why you're really not gonna help me just
because I don't have kids not that I
won't it's that I can't I am an entity
of untapped Cosmic potential
and I want a big family the biggest
family possible
I want every living thing on Earth to be
a direct descendant of me or one of my
followers
those that best serve that goal receive
a fraction of my power
my most devoted followers are bestowed
with gifts like extended life spans
rapid healing physical enhancement and
in some cases immortality
and those followers
are the ones looking for you
okay you on the other hand have closed
yourself off to my dark influence at our
mortal and vulnerable no kids no powers
what if I don't want powers or kids
I take an involuntary step backwards
okay I'm sorry
deserve that
uh uh yep I'm fine don't worry about me
let's move on to the next ritual so we
can get out of here okay
holy moly that was freaking scary she's
really taking this hard I better go get
this stuff for the next ritual also who
am I
who am I what is what is this
who is this no lust having nothing
you not who I think you is
all right anyway uh meat from a living
thing that died within the black woods
okay milk of the black goat
uh store about two percent is fine too
lastly a receptacle filled to the brim
with liquid life blood they mean blood
please use blood from now on
[Music]
all right cool all right so I need milk
and meat and blood I remember there
being a bucket of blood somewhere
listen I'm here for a smooch I'm here
for the biggest smooch I'm here for the
smooch of all smooches if you know what
I mean
so I don't know what about this no lust
having nothing
I want smooches
okay meat I tear a hunk of meat from the
hook this should be what I'm looking for
smells kind of strange is this Beef Pork
whatever it came from it was huge I
should move on before I count the number
of legs hanging on the hooks
all right Simon
unusually pungent spices
there was a bucket of blood here
somewhere milk of the black goat
it just looks like regular card in a
store-bought strawberry milk with a
label strapped on
every time getting the real thing for
Moroccan now that their relationship is
sour no pun intended I should be good
enough
yay probably yeah
then oh was there a bucket of blood in
here too great
oh good
an unsettling amount of blood I'll just
carry this children on my spine when
being watched have everything I need I
need to get out of here and fast
how fast oh fast
no okay
I did it okay
hello how are you
hey you're basically a God right yes if
these cultists have been bothering you
couldn't you I don't know what mother
would I be if I harmed my children hmm
I'm gonna take him but in all
seriousness I can't do anything to hurt
my followers directly because never in
my wildest dreams could I hurt a human
didn't you threaten to kill me what
maybe doing no harm isn't the same as
doing good
I suppose that's fair whatever that
means all right I need red I think
okay I need meat I have these things I'm
gonna put them in my hands I think
what do we do
two of them
I I have them
a horrigorian corner
looks like you did everything perfectly
impressive why did I do this I don't
even remember what the objective was
nothing to it if all the rituals are
this easy we might just get out of here
perhaps so I
guess they are between us
your life is your own I'm sorry for
losing my composure trust me
oh that I nearly forgot about that
already I'm a little surprised the
little God would bother apologizing
you're human at all
and while you may be blasphemously
abstinent you're the only person in the
world that can help me
abstinent if you step within range of my
Woods any desire you have that will lead
you closer to me is Amplified to such an
intense degree that it's unbearable
most of the time it's lost
[Music]
anyone who is Led here seeking carnal or
animalistic pressures develops the
Sacramento stare
that comes a cultist okay if you are
brought into my roots for any other
reason you don't become one of my chosen
thousands and your desire will make you
futile search the words for what isn't
there okay to eat and sleep and you'll
search and search until you die of
exhaustion and become fertilizer for the
woods to grow further the dark woods the
only person to reach me without joining
the cult or dropping dead
thanks in no small parts the fact that
you don't have lust to amplify
the only question is if you're not here
for lust
is lost
I pulled the receipt out of my pocket I
came looking for my parents this used to
be a handwritten letter from them saying
they were here in this house but once I
got here it turned into a blank receipt
and won't turn back
with your emotions to bring you here
that paper was likely never a letter
from your parents but the words made you
believe it was
sorry interesting
so they really aren't still alive they
were likely consumed by my Woods no more
than three days after they disappeared
that's oddly specific
I feel like I've been punched in the gut
the dust has long settled on my parents
being gone but
it'll give you your strength back the
woods won't let you feel how tired you
are
I won't let you feel how lustful I am
it's not really that lustful you're kind
of more goat than I'm Comfort which is
like not I'm not trying to say that
there's a delineation of amount of goat
that I'm comfortable with because that's
an uncomfortable statement to say but
you're quite goat you're basically goat
I don't feel tired at all come to think
of it I felt like I was gonna collapse
when I made it to this house I don't
think I've eaten since I got the letter
either
I take a few bites in the tears of baby
it'll be all right Stardust oh I'm so
sad give me a big hug
Stardust how did you know my parents
nickname oh did you know that thing that
dies within my blackboards becomes a
part oh part of me they're dead
their love for you likely lives on in me
then it would have been really weird if
you came on to me I guess that settles
it my parents are really gone that's the
only way she could do that
no never do that very special day but
maybe so goddamn special
that's outright terrifying but I feel
strangely comforted that part of them is
still there somewhere I hope this is an
offensive question but
how come this book said you were benign
you're kind of
that's not true I'm sorry all the
missing people the people that came
looking for them
I came bearing gifts of safe childbirth
for infinite mother
hungerlessness disease immunity uh-huh
not instead my own worshipers tormented
me until it broke my hearts hearts now
my Woods are bloodthirsty
I'm forced to watch innumerable die I
feel like I could number them but why
How could somebody do something like
that how could someone have so much hate
in their hearts oh
already
no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
I forgot Roxanne is just as scared as I
am I need to be more careful with
showing fear for her sake I need to be
brave it could just be the house this
place is old and brought this place is
old and rocking in some places so I
don't know sometimes the house shifts on
his own I'll check it out sound like it
came from the kitchen which is all the
across our
house stay here it's as far away from me
as
careful I'm sure no one's coming by you
didn't say anything about people being
drawn to you like a magnet because of
their lust right pretty sure okay
oh
another episode of Sucker For Love and
date to die for is coming up
[Music]
foreign
I guess at the end of it not nearly
enough smooching where was my smooching
uh fine okay well thank you everybody so
much for watching uh I don't know when
this is gonna fully come out and I don't
remember if I did say something or not
about voicing something in this game but
uh they I they'll know and this will
help me remember so thank you again
everybody so much for watching uh be
sure to check out the new drop at
cloakbrand.com and all the new uh stuff
that we have on sale regularly now we're
trying to get more stuff stock there
including slippers I think we have a few
pieces of underwear left and some of the
most comfortable pants you'll ever have
so thank you and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]